he'll the cigarettes ain't [ __ ] rich
language but you never hurt nobody take
a risk HP if you look up for the
[ __ ] this ain't it I just didn't let
us feed my defender drinking no zone
fire throat oh [ __ ] I'm a-going on going
Ueno bowtie jerk around us a boat Robbo
oh my mind kind of like a snow broke so
coked-out let's copy be shoppin eat oh
so nobody else dies lippy I said he'll
be mine like the trying goes right for
him if it goes right maybe bootleg ever
pick it on the show after no Locker that
Bichon song fun strong we got me staring
at a big long blonde I fear for the G
she had a big thumb gone didn't match I
tell she need a king kong's long dam up
another button in the answer to make up
for me into ring consider me and maybe
later I find an Asian Jake cuz I have to
make a bigger I'm just ripping that's
the [ __ ] I say when I beat your Guernica
don't bet there's a gift that was even
on whatever that mines dedicated to my
homie Center my [ __ ] dog manager can
control his temper when he call on the
back like I got a new number far from a
dude come on dude Anna a speech with a
joke coming up UConn 100 spring and she
was one of your monkey but you know but
you hit a handle but I'm funny girl on
your phone even do dollars do runner cuz
I'm feeling like I'm gonna get me lay a
cave in pack a business it's reached in
this [ __ ] but the homie lifted your
Geale
Beach Island let me hear that in the me
hair out of rusty y'all fix the Rusty's
box